good evening everyone and welcome to uh
thursday after thursday evening uh
morning to
guido uh on our python day and we'll
start off with
an interview with uh freedom from
and well what better way to start a
python evening
than to interview arguably the most
professional
monty python enthusiast in the world
and well asking from one dutch person to
another like how do you pronounce your
name
oh uh well in dutch obviously hiro
uh i think in belgium it would be hito
in
america i usually
take guido that's for people who sort of
remember the new jersey guidos uh
or guido for people whom are uh
spanish or french in their language
background
so whatever whatever you want to say i i
listen to anything that has the
e and o uh vowels in it so if someone
in a crowd calls hey people then i'll
probably
uh turn to call my name
yeah recognize that's good to know
so we want to start with a little bit of
early history um
python the language is based originally
on apc
language developed cwi here in amsterdam
and abc was aimed at non-professional
programmers and
especially designed for ease of use was
ease of use also an explicit goal for
python or
a leftover trait from abc
oh that's a good one i i think it was
i mean well nobody intentionally designs
a language to be hard to use so
i would say that that ease of use was
was very important
[Music]
uh my interest in languages from
from the sort of usability perspective
definitely came from the abc background
uh that and
i've sometimes said that the fact that
python is also
easy to learn even for people with no
programming background but that was
sort of a side benefit that came from
abc
that i didn't aim for because my
original target audience was definitely
professional programmers
okay and um
do you think that ease of use has
influenced the prevalence of python in
academia specifically and then
especially
the use of python data science
oh that's that's certain i think the
people who introduced python in that
field
that the scientists
who sort of heard about these and
oh that's a cool language that we could
use to help our
scientists write their scripts better
uh we're very conscious of the ease of
use
and and sort of the ease of learning and
the ease of use together
they're they're not exactly the same
property
but they often go hand in hand
now that's so that that that has
definitely made a big difference
and now a bit more recently um up until
july 2018 you served the python
community as a benevolent dictator for
life which
i find an amazing title since then you
have
stepped down from that position which
led to the new governance model
namely the steering console and
python 3.8 is the first version released
under this new governance model but
you still were part of this steering
console
and how's this experience been different
than serving as a bdfl both
for you and for python
it's it's been much less stressful
because
i'm not the person with the
the final responsibility for everything
that's
sort of in in the years that i
was bdfl i mean i sort of
wrote the code i tested the code
i reviewed contributions i managed the
source control system such as it was
i was the mailing list manager uh the
first time that i remember
delegating anything was around 94
when people said we or maybe it was 93
people anyway people
wanted a newsnet
news group and that was something that
was sort of fancier than a mail list and
more convenient
and and it would take
the administrative efforts away from me
and so i said sure but i don't know how
to do this
you all just do this you are using that
enthusiast make it happen
experience delegating
anything to the community uh but
and slowly of course of course
i delegated many other tasks uh
middle east moderator uh to offer all
those things
have been taken up by other people but
when it came to sort of
deciding which new features whether
it was to be considered a bug or a
feature
whether it was safe to backport the fix
a whole bunch of things
deciding on backwards compatibility
policy
and you'd be amazed at how many
different policies
exist for a large popular open source
project like this like how
does someone become a core developer uh
who gets the right to triage bugs in the
bug tracker which
book tracker do we use uh
do we extend the language to support a
certain
concept or activity better and
do we need the mo multi-line lambda
everything was my responsive
i i suffered from pretty severe burnout
i think leading up to my arrest
and then then there was a little
with with with uh
where social media just just got very
nasty and i
i can handle anonymous trolls on social
media just fine what i cannot handle is
when cordevs who i fought uh
respected me uh start disrespecting me
with nasty tweets uh and
so that's that that was it was very very
good to put all those things behind
and sort of let the core developers come
to
to an understanding of well
we we have to figure out for ourselves
what governance model we want
uh i joined the steering council or at
least i nominated myself
to be elected into the steering council
after like
five months or so of debate on what kind
of
what form of government we should have
finally when it was decided to
elect a steering council with five
people on it
i i i believe fairly last minute
i decided that it would be okay if i
nominated myself uh and so i
i served for a year on that steering
council
as one of the five people making these
final decisions
and sort of it was an exercise in
delegation
because the steering console sort of by
design
is written into the pep uh
while it has the same powers as the bdfl
had in the past there is a specific
sort of recommendation that the steering
council use
its powers to the least extent possible
so the steering council should not act
as a five-headed dictatorship
and randomly say we gotta do this we
gotta do that the steering council
should mostly
be ratifying what
appears to be the consensus or at least
the rough consensus of the core dev team
as a whole
and the steering council should also
sort of listen to outside voices for
example
data science world is very
important for python's future but there
are no core developers
from that world so one of the
responsibilities of the
steering council is to to actually
listen uh
to the needs of of of data science
in python and i've totally lost track of
the question if it was about
how i how i feel now i know i'm no
longer bdfl or whatever but
i can go on about this topic forever but
maybe you have a follow-up question or
something else
i think that was a lengthy and very
on-point
answer um um so you mentioned that you
nominated yourself for the steering
council previously
was it a conscious decision beforehand
to only
be on the syrian council for one year or
could you maybe elaborate on why you
have not
decided to nominate yourself again
i'm i'm usually not very good at making
at sort of having long-term
prediction of the future uh
so honestly i do not recall
whether i sort of meant to serve for
only one year
or whether i i had any opinion on that i
think that
i i know that one of the reasons i
figured i
should be a member or i wanted to be a
member of the
the first steering council was
definitely to provide some amount of
continuity because
one of my roles traditionally has also
been
to to be sort of the
the long-term memory to to sort of
remember how things were done in the
past
why pieces of code were there
uh who was involved in which
project and i thought it would be useful
for the steering council to
uh to sort of
have have my advice in in that sense and
of course i could have
done that without being a member but
yeah but after five or six months had
had passed i was also my burnout was a
little less
and so i was was more willing to to
participate and then
after year it was was actually
not at all clear first i thought i will
not
nominate myself for a second term
then people ask me will you run
please run and
so i said well okay if you want to
nominate me nominate me
and so briefly i was nominated and then
i realized
well actually
i i feel another period of burnout
coming on
uh and
we we see good candidates
besides the the sitting members
uh and i want to give sort of more
candidates a chance to actually
uh serve on the council and so then i
withdrew my nomination
just before the election started okay
and that's definitely that's that was
the right turned out to be the right
decision
um i'm glad to hear that especially
given
that you have dealt with uh burnouts in
the past
i'm no stranger to it myself um
in the lead up towards the um steering
council
of course there was a very high bus
factor with you as a
bdfl i can assume that that
also contributed to it and you never
know what people mean when they say
bus factor that that's a term from
from hardware design that
i sort of remember hearing in the 70s or
80s but
but have actually forgotten what it
means and and sometimes i think it's a
jocular reference to the question what
if guido were hit by a bus but
so i don't actually know what it means
so can you translate that for me first
that's that's exactly what it means it's
taken into consideration that a huge
you were you or are uh sbdfl a huge part
of the project
if you were to suddenly not be able to
participate or
act as a bdfl what would happen and what
impact would that have
on the project of python um
so i guess the question is was there
ever any talk of
alternative forms of governance for
example in the form of a steering
council
to take that responsibility a little bit
away from just you
and divide it over multiple people
that's the good question and i do not
recall there being
any serious discussions
about a different form of governance or
leadership or
however you want to to mention it it's
always actually been i mean bdfl was
just like a joke title it wasn't really
a defined role or anything there were
some mentions
of this such a thing needs to be
approved by the bdfl
but that was just a shorthand for by
guido penrasa
and so
i do remember but only in the
the last few years before my resignation
that some people started talking about
sort of project continuity
which apparently was was a thing that
some other open source projects had
had sort of seriously considered
uh my own feelings about that had
always been well uh there's a whole
community
of core devs and there are a number of
people
who who can be sort of considered as
lieutenants although we
we've never sort of explicitly named
them and we still don't
but they're they're very capable people
who have been
in this community for a very long time
and i totally trust them to
sort of continue python
in totally in the spirit of
of how how i've always been been
treating it
just hearing yeah the steering council
is is sort of
a version of that
but i was never really really worried
about python's future if i were to
to suddenly have to leave because
there there were just enough people who
who knew exactly what i would say and
what i would do
okay cool thank you um so a little bit
more about
well python history but a little bit
later than we were just talking about
uh python 3 was released in 2008 and
python 2.7 was released in july
uh 2010 that's both quite a long time
ago
however python 2.7 was only deprecated
last january and was still widely used
for a long time after
3.0 was released can you give us some
insight
as to why the adoption of python 3 took
so long
that is a topic that can easily fill the
remainder of an hour
uh i've given a talk about that at
uh by cascades uh
uh conference a few years ago i believe
that
one of the the big things that happened
was that the core team was not
actually aware of how
successful and python was by them
uh and we didn't realize that
a large number of python users and a
large amount of python code
was written by people who
sort of produced code and then moved on
rather than sort of caring about that
code
and sort of continually updating it
and keeping it up to date so
where we ourselves thought nothing of
taking a module and sort of seeing oh
this uses an antiquated api let's change
all uses of hask key
with the new in operator or something
like that
there were a large number of people who
didn't care about their code that way
uh probably
didn't have the programming skills and
the experience to to sort of effectively
implement
conversions like that and
sort of just generally
weren't weren't as interested in
in python and python code as
as sort of the core team was but
nevertheless
all those people had large and important
code
bases that did something important
in their group or organization or
company
and so like half a year ago or so i got
together with
a bunch of folks in london one of whom
has run a small python consulting
company
forever and so he
he told stories about customers where
the typical way his
company sort of made money was
they were approached by a customer who
had a problem that they could solve for
them
they wrote a bunch of custom code
installed it on
a piece of hardware and then moved on
and maybe they had a small contract to
keep the hardware up and running
but the customer wouldn't necessarily
want to pay
to upgrade that code to a new version of
python
if they didn't have a need to have that
that code sort of do something new
and most of these customers are barely
aware
or not all that interested in sort of
the issue of security vulnerabilities
well considering maintaining and
upgrading your code
quite recently or well in 3.9
a new parser for c python is being
introduced which you have
worked on and written on quite
extensively
this is quite a big change and
yeah my first question would be like why
now
why is this the time to upgrade the
parser
well it's debatable whether it's big
change
of course in three nine the old parser
is still around
and accepts exactly the same syntax as
the new parser
but there's one difference oh i'll leave
it for
people to find out on their own what
that difference is
uh so there's a little easter egg there
a little homework
how do you read the grammar you can find
it probably
but but anyway yeah why why now
uh
because the old parser was 30 years old
and could not
actually parse certain constructs
in the language the oldest of those was
probably keyword
uh arguments in function calls
and if you look at the old grammar this
the grammar for keyword arguments is
literally
expression equals expression
and then there is a separate semantic
pass
that sort of sits between the parser and
the code generator that
says well if we see an argument of the
form expression
equals expression then we go check the
the first of those expressions to see
that it
is actually just a simple name
and i believe until up through 3.6 or
3.7 there was a bug in that code
that made it so that if you put
parentheses
around the keyword on the left-hand side
of the equal sign it would still work
because that second that second check
sort of checked the shape of the
abstract syntax tree
and in the abstract syntax tree there is
the parentheses are all implicit
okay so the whole sort of
there were various smaller and larger
issues with the
the old parser as as sort of
a tool chain and that will allow us to
to sort of add new
grammar to the language more easily and
i have i have something
in the works for 3.10 that i'm not ready
to reveal yet
oh exciting uh we'll definitely keep an
eye on out for that and
um well you mentioned like i called it
quite a big change
uh how much ever does such a change take
and also you've been working on this
with pablo
who was interviewed this afternoon
um how did that process go
uh well i should say that that actually
the third co collaborator on the project
was lisandros
a greek computer science student uh at
the university of berlin
uh
it it was definitely a big project
uh we we had a few moments
where the three of us were sprinting
to the almost to the point of breaking
because we
we had sort of
we had a deadline to make the the first
deadline i remember wanting to make is
getting the
pep in front of
of cordev's at the
language summit uh
and the next that and so we worked
really hard to have something working
at that point plus we we worked on a
presentation
but we at that point we we basically had
solved the basic problem and we had a
working parser
and we were already just sort of
tweaking compatibility with the old
parser and figuring out
ways of measuring how compatible it
really was with the old parser
uh then the next deadline came very
quickly after that
a week after the language summit the
steering council actually approved our
pep
uh and then we had about one week to get
the pep
to to get the implementation ready to
uh be put in
uh in the the last alpha release where
it was no it was not the last
i think it was alpha five that we wanted
to get it into
and after that that would be alpha six
and then data one and so on
beta 1 would have been absolutely last
one but it would have been pretty bad to
take such a big refactoring
and shove it into the first data and
then
let the beta users uh test it out
so i remember
leading up to alpha five we suddenly
realized
that where we thought we were very
compatible
uh we had not been testing
running the tests in the right way and
all sorts of corner cases for which
there were explicit unit tests
uh in the the standard test tweets for
python
uh weren't covered and so then we really
had to work our asses off and we we
ended up asking the
release manager for a two-day extension
so that we could get
last issue resolved
and that that was a pretty stressful uh
weekend to be honest
i can't imagine i can imagine well after
that things
things went relatively smoothly and i'm
very happy with
the overall outcome it went exactly as i
i hoped it would that's good that's good
um then as a little bit of a closing
note before we can take maybe one
question from the audience
contributor diversity is important to
you and to us each year we
award a number of diversity scholarships
to people who might not otherwise be
able to
attend the conference to hope that it
remains accessible
would you like to say something to the
people at the conference this year at
the spider festival in the attendee list
who received the diversity scholarship
hi that that's that's like
people come from such diverse
backgrounds
uh i'm not sure what to say i'm
i'm that would be terrible as a
commencement uh
or motivational speaker that's for sure
i welcome everyone in in the community
i i hope that they're attending the
conference will
will sort of get them more involved in
the community
i hope that the community is is
on its best behavior
uh and i hope that that we will have
a more diverse community membership as a
result of
of these kind of sponsors sponsorships
or
well thank you um
we have about one minute left so that's
not that much we have a couple of
questions from the audience
um
so let's see which one has the most
others um there's exactly one question
with one up vote
yeah there's exactly one um dennis asks
oh there are more of course
the votes would matter right yeah we ask
people
oh every every question that makes it a
lot easier to choose
okay so we're going to we're just going
to uh um
ask the anonymous question a while back
someone says
that an anonymous person says a while
back i remember seeing an exchange
between
hito and david beasley in which david
stated the feeling of
python and the community has changed for
him over time
hito mentioned the influence of data
science which always left me wondering
what he meant
could you maybe shine some light on this
hero purely out of interest
okay well now you you have to realize
what what this anonymous attendee
doesn't mention is that the whole
exchange happened on twitter
honestly i usually don't understand what
dave beasley is
tweeting about
and i usually only hear about something
he tweets when
when someone sort of says guido you
should look at it
at this because i i cannot keep up with
my
main twitter stream so i basically
twitter
is permanently open just on people who
tag me
what i mentioned about the influence of
data science
data science has brought a
large and rather
different from the original group
of uh python users
into the community
before data science was a thing i would
expect that the majority of python users
if if they weren't like educational
enthusiasts which
was mostly a small group they were
serious programmers who wanted
a good scripting language
uh and there was there was sort of
python was lumped in the same corner as
php and pearl
and uh
to even tickle tk
and uh serious python users were
probably doing web development
that for for a long time from the late
90s to
uh the mid arts
web development was one of python's uh
killer apps and then just
like scripting and tooling i i joined
google
at a time where google was not using
python for web development i
doubt that they actually ever had but it
was
the major language for writing tools
uh that stayed inside the company so
and and google is very good at tooling i
should say i don't know if they still
write all their tools in
python but i'm sure that there still is
an
enormous amount of python at google
uh and so data science
somehow became prominent
as a separate activity and
somehow some early data science users
adopted python and started writing
libraries for python
and that brought in a whole different
crowd of users who
often were not professional programmers
but maybe
professional statisticians or
professional
just researchers i mean the number of
of people who have written a phd using
python code
for for their data handling
must be enormous and
that that sort of
it's just a different different type of
users and i
i remember sort of attending an early
pie
data conference
i think it was in a small meeting room
at google actually
uh
and the the
the talks the people were different one
thing was that there was actually there
were more
suits and there was more there were more
people who were thinking
seriously about business and
really that's that's all i have to say
about that particular exchange
all right well um
then i think that's a good point to end
um
well my personal pi data experience is
not with a lot of suits but
that's uh maybe a topic for another time
um
we would like to thank you very much for
your time
and for your insights